in january the long beach city council
passed an
ordinance requiring a four-month four
dollar an hour
pay boost for employees of large grocery
store chains
they called it hero pay for essential
workers
often overlooked during the pandemic
when we looked at it
it was very clear that grocery workers
were interacting with
more people daily than probably any
other profession
and they were being incredibly
overworked and they deserved that
additional support
they weren't expecting the backlash the
state's grocery association
filed suit to block the extra pay and
kroger one of the us's biggest
supermarket chains
abruptly announced it would close two
long beach stores
leaving 200 employees jobs in doubt eric
cortez has worked for kroger for 14
years
he showed us a letter sent to employees
this
advise you of our company's decision to
close and permanently terminate
the entirety of the operations of
business and economic reasons
including the economic costs mandated by
the long beach ordinance
what shocked employees and politicians
is that grocery chains made
enormous profits last year coveted 19
restrictions on restaurants meant
more people bought food to cook at home
big grocery chains
kroger in particular are rolling in
money
kroger is a real standout so kroger in
the first three quarters
of 2020 when you look at their net
earnings their total profits
they have doubled their profit compared
to 2019 so they earned an additional 1.3
billion dollars in profits
that's an astonishing growth and if you
figured kroger would
share some of that bonanza with its
workers guess again
by and large the companies have not
passed these windfall profits on to
their workers who
is important to a note that grocery and
retail workers typically earn very low
wages
cortes and his co-workers are
disappointed and
angry well i just think that they're
being greedy the california grocers
association says
its members have had to buy protective
equipment or ppe
they have not considered all of the
expenses that we have paid
in ppe long beach mayor robert garcia
says it's simply a matter of fairness
they deserve these few extra bucks
just for a few months to help them and
their families but workers
may get the last word more and more
california cities have approved
or are in the process of approving hero
pay
including los angeles oakland irvine and
san jose rob reynolds al jazeera long
beach
california